قواتنا تعمل على مدار الساعات ضد كل من
يريد المسافه باسرائيل والمبدا بسيط فمن
يحاول الاضرار بنا سوف يقتل
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم البدايه من التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه حيث اعلنت
عرين الاسود استشهاد ثلاثه من افرادها
خلال الشباك مع الاحتلال بينما توعدت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بالرد اما نتنياهو
فقال ان كل من يحاول المسافه بامن اسرائيل
سوف يقتل حسب تعبيره في حين كشفت مصادر
انه ارجى قرار تشريع بؤر استيطانيه الى
بعد شهر رمضان خشيه تفجر الاوضاع جبهات
القتال تشتعل في شرقي وجنوب اوكرانيا
ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه تعلن السيطره على
مواقع وصفتها بالمهمه داخل المنطقه
الصناعيه في باخموت في حين اكدت قياده
عمليات الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني انها
تعمل لدفع القوات الروسيه الى تراجع في
الضفه اليسرى من خيرسون رغم استمرار
الاحتجاجات الرافضه له في عموم البلاد
مجلس شيوخ الفرنسي يصدق على مشروع قانون
تعديل نظام التقاعد تمهيدا لاقراره بشكل
نهائي بموافقه
195 صوتا مقابل معارضه 112 ورؤساء النقبات
العماليه يطالبون ماكرون باستفتاء الشعر
مخاوف في واشنطن من انتقال عدوى افلاس بنك
وادي سيليكون اكبر مقردا لشركات تكنولوجيا
الناشئه الى بنوك اقليميه اخرى مع قصر
المهله الممنوحه لايجاد مشترك في حين اقر
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك بوجود
قلق من تاثيرات افلاس البنك على بريطانيا
الى اللقاء